which dinosaur is the biggest let's take
a look at just how much of a difference
there is between all the dinosaurs in
the Jurassic Park and Jurassic world
films comparing the sizes of some of
your favorites including the
Velociraptor and the indominus Rex most
of all though I'll show you which
dinosaur is the biggest out of all of
them we've seen and here's a hint it's
not the T-Rex or the mosasaurus one
thing to keep in mind with these size
comparisons is that most of the
measurements are estimates from real
life fossils and from what we've seen in
the movies anyways let's start off with
the smallest dinosaur in any of the
Jurassic Park and Jurassic world films
the compsognathus measuring at 0.65
meters long with a weight of 0.83
kilograms this was one of the smallest
known dinosaurs with its name meaning
elegant jaw and it actually may have had
feathers these small pack hunting
carnivores first appeared in the Lost
World Jurassic Park where they attacked
a young girl in Isla sorna and later
killed Dieter Stark they also appeared
in Jurassic Park 3 where they chased
Eric Kirby and Alan Grant they were seen
again in Jurassic world Fallen Kingdom
where they escaped Lockwood Manor and
attacked some people in California up
next is the microseritus measuring at
0.76 meters long and weighing 4
kilograms its name means small horned
and it had 2 small horns on its frill
and a beak-like mouth these tiny
herbivores with horn snouts weren't
directly seen in the films but they were
mentioned on the Jurassic World website
as one of the attractions of the park
next up is the dimorphodon with a length
of one meter and a weight of one to two
kilograms although it's not a true
dinosaur but a flying reptile its name
means two form tooth it had a large head
and a long tail these flying reptiles
with large heads and teeth were seen in
Jurassic world where they escaped their
Aviary and attacked the visitors of the
park they also appeared in Jurassic
world Fallen Kingdom where they were
captured by mercenaries and later freed
by Maisie Lockwood up next is the
lystrosaurus also measuring at one meter
but weighing 30 kilograms again not a
true dinosaur but a mammal-like reptile
its name means shovel lizard it had two
tusks and a beak these mammal-like
reptiles live before the dinosaurs but
they were cloned by ingen for unknown
reasons they were briefly seen in
Jurassic world Fallen Kingdom where they
were among the animals auctioned at the
Lockwood Manor the next largest dinosaur
is the moros with a length of 1.2 meters
and weighing 78 kilograms as one of the
earliest Tyrannosaurs its name means
doom and it was fast and agile these
small theropods were not seen in the
films but they were featured in the
Jurassic world Dominion prologue where
they chased a group of other dinosaurs
in the Cretaceous Period up next is the
oviraptor with a length of 1.5 to 2
meters and a weight of 36 to 45
kilograms its name means egg Thief it
had a toothless beak and a Crest on its
head and it may have brooded its eggs
like a bird although these dinosaurs
weren't specifically seen in the films
they were mentioned in the Jurassic Park
novel where they were erroneously
identified as egg thieves they also
appeared in some video games and comics
based on the franchise the next largest
dinosaur is the Velociraptor a fan
favorite measuring at 1.8 meters and 15
kilograms in weight its name means Swift
Thief it had a sickle-shaped claw on
each foot and may have actually been
feathered these intelligent and social
predators are one of the main
attractions and threats of the franchise
they appeared in all six films usually
as antagonists but also as allies of
some of the human characters lastly they
have different color patterns and sizes
depending on the film next up is the
atrasa Raptor also measuring at 1.8
meters but weighing 20 kilograms its
name means Savage Thief it had long
serrated teeth and strong jaws and was
closely related to the Velociraptor
although they weren't seen in the films
they were featured in some of the video
games and comics based on the franchise
next we have the Pyro Raptor also
measuring at 1.8 meters and weighing 20
to 40 kilograms its name means fire
thief and it was discovered after a
forest fire in France it had long arms
and curved Claws and was also featured
in some of the video games and comics
based on the franchise next we have the
dimetrodon with a length of 2 meters and
a weight of 28 to 250 kilograms this
synapsid reptile's name means to measure
tooth and it had a large Sail on its
back it was mentioned in the Jurassic
Park novel where it was cloned by ingen
as an experiment next is the Smilodon
with a length of 2 meters and a weight
of 55 to 400 kilograms although not a
true dinosaur but an extinct cat its
name means knife tooth it had long
curved fangs and powerful jaws this
saber-toothed cat that lived after the
dinosaurs was not seen in the films but
was mentioned in the Jurassic Park novel
where it was cloned by engine as another
experiment the next largest is the
stagey Malik with a length of 3 meters
and a weight of 100 kilograms its name
means stick devil and it had a
dome-shaped skull with spikes and horns
this dinosaur was seen in Jurassic world
Fallen Kingdom where where it helped
Owen Grady and Claire Deering escape
from their cell at the Lockwood Manor it
also appeared in Jurassic world Camp
Cretaceous where it befriended Ben
Pinkus up next is the notha source with
a length of four to six meters although
not a true dinosaur but a marine reptile
its name means a false lizard it had
webbed feet and a long tail and was
mentioned on the Jurassic World website
as one of the attractions of the Park's
Cretaceous Cruise the next largest
dinosaur is the Pachycephalosaurus with
the length of 4.5 meters and a weight of
450 kilograms its name means
thick-headed lizard and it had a
dome-shaped skull up to 25 centimeters
thick this skull was used for display
and combat and was seen in the Lost
World Jurassic Park where it ran through
San Diego after escaping from a cargo
ship it also appeared in Jurassic world
where it was used for gyrosphere Valley
it also appeared in Jurassic world
Fallen Kingdom where it escaped from the
Lockwood Manor the next largest dinosaur
is the nasudoceratops with a length of
4.5 meters and weighing approximately
2.5 tons its name means large-nosed
horned face and added large nose and
long curved horns above its eyes and was
closely related to the Triceratops this
herbivore was seen in and battle at Big
Rock where it fought against an
Allosaurus that attacked its family it
also appeared in Jurassic world Camp
Cretaceous where interacted with the
campers next up we have the
monolophosaurus with a length of five to
six meters its name means a single
crested lizard and had a single Ridge on
top of its skull it too was mentioned on
the Jurassic World website as one of the
main attractions of the park and was
featured in some video games and comics
based on the franchise the next largest
dinosaur is the Kentrosaurus with a
length of 5.5 meters and a weight of 2
tons its name means spiked lizard as it
had two rows of plates on its back and
spikes on its tail and hips although it
wasn't seen in the films this dinosaur
was mentioned in the Jurassic Park novel
where it was cloned by in-gen for
Jurassic Park next up is the
dilophosaurus with a length of 6 meters
and a weight of 280 kilograms its name
means two crested lizard as it had two
Thin crests on its skull although it
didn't actually spit venom or have a
frill like in Jurassic Park this
carnivore was seen spitting Venom in
Jurassic Park when it killed Dennis
nedry after he stole dinosaur embryos it
also appeared in Jurassic Road Camp
Cretaceous where it chased the campers
next we have the ceratosaurus with a
length of 6 meters and away weight of
0.5 to 1 tons its name means horned
lizard as it had a horn on its nose and
bony ridges over its eyes this carnivore
was seen in Jurassic Park 3 where it
encountered Alan Grant and his group
near a pile of Spinosaurus dung it also
appeared in Jurassic world Camp
Cretaceous where it fought against the
Baryonyx the next largest dinosaur is
the cenoceratops with a length of 6
meters and a weight of approximately two
tons its name means Chinese horned face
as it was the first ceratopsian
discovered in China it had a frill with
hooks and knobs and was seen in Jurassic
world Fallen Kingdom where it saved Owen
Grady from the Carnotaurus and later
escaped from the Lockwood Manor it also
appeared in Jurassic world Camp
Cretaceous where it interacted with the
campers up next is the Ankylosaurus with
a length of six to eight meters and a
weight of four to eight tons its name
means fused lizard it had a heavily
armored body and a club-like tail and
was one of the last non-avian dinosaurs
to exist this herbivore was seen in
Jurassic Park 3 where it was briefly
glimpsed by Alan Grant and his group it
also appeared in Jurassic world where it
fought against the indominus Rex and
later escaped from the park it also
appeared in Jurassic world Fallen
Kingdom where it was captured by
mercenaries and later freed by Maisie
lock wood next up is the indoraptor with
an estimated length of 7.3 meters and an
unknown weight although not a real
dinosaur but a genetically engineered
hybrid from Jurassic world Fallen
Kingdom it was created from the DNA of
indominus Rex and the Velociraptor this
hybrid was created by Henry Wu and Eli
Mills as a weaponized dinosaur it was
the main antagonist of Jurassic world
Fallen Kingdom where it killed several
people at the Lockwood Manor before
being killed by the Velociraptor blue if
you want to dive deeper into the world
of Jurassic Park then check out
Universal's digital movie store where
you can get your very own digital copy
of the entire Jurassic Park series and
celebration of the franchise's 30th
Anniversary buy it once and watch all
the films on any of your devices on
Apple TV Prime video Voodoo Google play
YouTube DirecTV or anywhere you watch
your digital movies and never worry
about losing access to your library or
having to watch ads click the Creator
cart Link in the video description to
get 30 off any Jurassic Park movie or
bundle and enter to win some awesome
Jurassic Park merch thanks again to
Universal pictures for sponsoring this
video now let's get back to the
Dinosaurs the next largest dinosaur is
the Baryonyx with a length of seven
point 5 meters and a weight of 1.2 tons
its name means heavy claw as it had a
large Claw on each hand and a long
crocodile-like snout this carnivore was
seen in Jurassic world Fallen Kingdom
where it attacked clear Deering and
Franklin Webb inside a bunker on Easley
newbar it also appeared in Jurassic
world Camp Cretaceous where it chased
the campers next we have the Carnotaurus
with a length of 7.5 to 9 meters and a
weight of one to two tons its name means
meat eating bowl and it had two short
horns above its eyes and very small arms
this carnivore was seen in Jurassic
world Fallen Kingdom where it tried to
attack Owen Grady and Claire Deering on
Isla newbar but was killed by the
volcanic eruption it also appeared in
Jurassic world Camp Cretaceous where it
fought against the sinuseratops the next
largest dinosaur is the Allosaurus with
a length of 8.5 meters and a weight of
2.3 tons its name means different lizard
it was one of the largest predators of
its time and it had three fingered hands
and a large skull this large carnivore
was seen in Jurassic world Fallen
Kingdom where it escaped from easel and
ubar and was auctioned at the Lockwood
Manor it also appeared in battle at Big
Rock where it attacked a family of
nasudoceratops and some humans at a
campground lastly it appeared in
Jurassic World Camp Cretaceous where it
also chased the campers next up is the
Corey thesaurus with a length of 9
meters and a weight of 4 tons its name
means helmet lizard and it had a large
Hollow Crest on its head which it may
have used to make sounds this herbivore
was seen in Jurassic Park 3 where it was
briefly glimpsed by Alan Grant and his
group it also appeared in Jurassic world
Fallen Kingdom where it was captured by
mercenaries and later freed by Maisie
Lockwood next up is the stegosaurus with
a length of 9 meters and a weight of 2.5
to 3.5 tons its name means roof lizard
as it had two rows of plates on its back
and four spikes on its tail this
herbivore was seen in the Lost World
Jurassic Park where it encountered Sarah
Harding and her group on Isla sorna it
also appeared in Jurassic Park 3 where
it was briefly glimpsed by Alan Grant
and his group it also appeared in
Jurassic world where it was used for a
petting zoo attraction called gentle
Giants petting zoo lastly it appeared in
Jurassic world Fallen Kingdom where it
escaped from Isla newbar and was
auctioned at the Lockwood Manor next is
the Triceratops with a length of 9
meters and a weight of 6 to 12 tons its
name means three-horned face as it had
three horns on its face and a large
frill and it was one of the most common
and well-known dinosaurs of all time
this herbivore was seen in Jurassic Park
where it was sick due to eating
poisonous plants and was treated by
Ellie Sattler it also appeared in the
Lost World Jurassic Park where it
defended its baby from Peter Ludlow and
its Hunters it also appeared in Jurassic
Park 3 where it was briefly glimpsed by
Alan Grant and his group and in Jurassic
world where it was used for a riding
attraction called Triceratops territory
lastly it also appeared in Jurassic
world Fallen Kingdom where escape from
easel newbar and was auctioned at the
Lockwood Manor the next largest dinosaur
is the Parasaurolophus with the length
of 9.5 meters and a weight of 2.5 tons
its name means near crested lizard and
had a long curved Crest on its head this
herbivore was seen in the Lost World
Jurassic Park where it ran away from the
Indian Hunters on easily sorna it also
appeared in Jurassic world where it was
also used for the gentle Giants petting
zoo attraction and in Jurassic world
Fallen Kingdom where it escaped from
Isla newbar and was auctioned at the
Lockwood Manor next up is the Iguanodon
with a length of 10 meters and a weight
of 3 to 4 tons its name means iguana
tooth and it was one of the first
dinosaurs to ever be discovered this
herbivore with the thumb Spike and in
hoof-like fingers wasn't seen in the
films but it was mentioned in the
Jurassic Park novel where it was owned
by Engen for Jurassic Park it also
appeared in some video games and comics
based on the franchise next is the
Tarbosaurus with a length of 10 to 12
meters and a weight of 4 to 5 tons its
name means alarming lizard and it was
very similar to the Tyrannosaurus Rex
but had a narrower skull and longer arms
although it wasn't featured in the films
it was seen in some video games and
comics based on the franchise the next
largest dinosaur is the gigantosaurus
with a length of 12 to 13 meters and a
weight of approximately 6 to 13 tons its
name means giant Southern lizard and it
was one of the largest meat-eating
dinosaurs ever this huge carnivore
appeared in Jurassic world Dominion
where it fought against the
Tyrannosaurus Rex the next largest
dinosaur is the Tyrannosaurus Rex with a
length of 12 to 13 meters and a weight
of approximately 5.4 to 14 tons its name
means Tyrant Lizard King and was one of
the most famous and fearsome dinosaurs
ever it had a massive skull powerful
jaws and Tiny Arms This iconic carnivore
is one of the main attractions and
threats of the franchise it appeared in
all six films usually as an antagonist
but also as a hero sometimes next is the
mosasaurus with the length of 15 to 18
meters and an known weight although not
a true dinosaur but a marine reptile its
name means Muse lizard and had a long
crocodile-like body and powerful jaws
with sharp teeth it was the apex
predator of the ancient seas and was
seen in the film Jurassic world where it
was used for a show called The
mosasaurus feeding show it also appeared
in Jurassic world Fallen Kingdom where
it escaped from its Lagoon and attacked
some people at Sea the next largest
dinosaur is the Spinosaurus with the
length of 15 to 18 meters an approximate
weight of 7 to 20 tons its name means
spine lizard and had a sail-like
structure on its back and a long narrow
snout this carnivore was the main
antagonist of Jurassic Park 3 where it
killed the Tyrannosaurus Rex and chased
Alan Grant and his group throughout
easily sorna it also appeared in some
video games and comics based on the
franchise next up is the indominus Rex
with a length of 15.2 meters and an
unknown weight although not a real
dinosaur but a genetically engineered
hybrid from Jurassic world it was
created from the DNA of the
Tyrannosaurus Rex Velociraptor and other
animals this hybrid was created by Henry
Wu and Simon mezrani as a new attraction
for Jurassic world it was the main
antagonist of the film where it escaped
from its enclosure and killed several
dinosaurs and humans before being killed
by a mosasaurus next up is the
quetzalcoatlas with a 15.9 meter
wingspan and a weight of approximately
200 to 250 kilograms although not a true
dinosaur but a flying reptile its name
means a feathered serpent God and is one
of the largest flying animals of all
time this flying reptile was mentioned
in the Jurassic World website as one of
the main attractions of the Park's
Aviary it also appeared in some video
games and comics based on Jurassic Park
the next largest dinosaur is the
brachiosaurus with a length of 18 to 21
meters and an approximate weight of 28
to 35 tons its name means arm lizard and
it had longer front legs than back legs
and a giraffe-like stance this herbivore
was seen in Jurassic Park where it
amazed Alan Grant and Ellie Sadler when
they first arrived at easel and nubar it
also appeared in the Lost World Jurassic
Park where it ran away from the Indian
Hunters on izales Orna it also appeared
in Jurassic Park 3 where it was briefly
glimpsed by Alan Grant and his group and
in Jurassic world where it was used for
a safari attraction called gyrosphere
lastly it appeared in Jurassic world
Fallen Kingdom where it died on Isla
newbar due to the volcanic eruption next
up is the with a length of 21 to 23
meters and a weight of 16 to 22 tons its
name means a deceptive lizard and it was
formerly known as the Brontosaurus and
had a long neck and tail and a bulky
body and was seen in Jurassic world
where it was also used for the Safari
attraction called gyrosphere it later
appeared in Jurassic world Fallen
Kingdom where it escaped from Isla
newbar and was auctioned at the Lockwood
Manor the next largest dinosaur is the
momentkiosaurus with a length of 21 to
35 meters and an unknown weight possibly
over 50 tons its name means momentky
lizard and had one of the longest necks
of any animal up to 15 meters long this
herbivore was seen in the Lost World
Jurassic Park where it walked over the
Indian camp on easily sorna now for the
runner-up as the second largest dinosaur
in any of the Jurassic Park titles we
have the dreadnaughtus with a length of
26 meters and an approximate weight of
38 tons its name means fears nothing and
it was one of the heaviest and most
complete sauropods ever found this
herbivore was seen during a flashback of
the Cretaceous Period and Jurassic world
Dominion in this scene some
dreadnaughtas were seen near a lake with
a flock of tyrandon and quetzalcoatlas
now for the largest dinosaur scene in
any of the Jurassic Park and Jurassic
world titles we have the Argentinosaurus
with the length of 30 to 40 meters and
an approximate weight of 50 to 100 tons
this dinosaur's name means Argentine
lizard and is one of the largest and
heaviest dinosaurs ever it had a long
neck and tail and a relatively small
head this herbivore wasn't actually seen
in the films but was featured in some
video games and comics based on the
franchise including Jurassic World the
game Jurassic world alive and Jurassic
world Evolution 2. subscribe for more
content about your favorite movies and
if you liked the video check out the one
on your screen too
foreign